The gritty world of "The Batman" is filled with
intrigue and corruption. But as the credits roll,
there is a lot left unresolved. Keep
watching to learn the biggest unanswered
questions from "The Batman."
Perhaps the biggest tease for Batman's future
clash with villainy is the mysterious character
sitting in the cell right next to the Riddler
at the end of the film. He offers the Riddler
friendship or an alliance in an effort to stage
a "comeback" story for the people of Gotham.
At first glance, it seems like the figure might
be some kind of revamped take on Two-Face.
His hair is unkempt and it appears that his face
may be disfigured, at least on the one side that
the audience is allowed to see. Furthermore,
Batman fans will recognize that Carmine
Falcone's operations were busted wide open by law
enforcement prior to the events of the film. In
Jeph Loeb's "The Long Halloween," it's Falcone's
legal woes and his rivalry with Sal Maroni that
result in Harvey Dent being splashed with acid
by a mobster during his testimony in court.
This could have already occurred prior to "The
Batman," especially since Gil Colson is the D.A.,
and there is no mention of Harvey Dent.
However, that cackle isn't necessarily
something Two-Face is known for. In fact,
it's far more reminiscent of the Joker.
"Just an old friend, who's
dying to do me a favor.”
[cackling]
The Riddler is very thorough when he goes
combing through the history books of Gotham City
in an attempt to eliminate every bit of corruption
he can find. The Riddler's mission becomes clear:
kill a corrupt official, then destroy their
reputation by outing their dirty deeds on the
nightly news. During his vigilante crusade, he
targets the Wayne family. Among his newspaper
clippings is one that highlights a seeming
partnership between Thomas Wayne and crime
boss Carmine Falcone. And in that stack, one
headline can be seen referencing Edward Elliot.
The Riddler clearly has his eye on the Wayne and
Arkham families who helped establish Gotham City.
However, Edward Elliot was also a wealthy
aristocrat who played a fundamental role in
modernizing the city. In the comics,
he's an ancestor of Thomas Elliot,
who was Bruce Wayne's friend when they were kids.
He later turned to a life of crime, adopting the
moniker of Hush and using his talents and medical
expertise to wage war against Bruce. Underneath it
all, Thomas was envious of Bruce's life despite
the tragedy that he suffered in Crime Alley as
a young boy. This villain's nefarious deeds are
ultimately very personal for Batman as a result.
Now that we know the Elliot family exists within
the Gotham City of "The Batman," there's always a
chance that Hush could take center stage.
The Riddler highlighted two of
Gotham's most elite families:
the Waynes and the Arkhams. During the Riddler's
crusade against the corrupt powers in Gotham,
he discusses Thomas Wayne's culpability for
working with the mob and associating with
the likes of Carmine Falcone. Even though
the Riddler brings up the two families,
he really only focuses on the Waynes and their
closeted collaboration with organized crime.
"You're a part of this too."
"How am I a part of this?"
"You'll see."
The Arkham family is
never discussed in great detail. Is the Arkham
family still active in Gotham? Or is the famous
holding asylum that bears their family name the
only real claim to fame? Clearly, the Riddler
didn't attack anyone within the Arkham family.
That could be because their lineage is no more,
or because the living Arkham family members are
squeaky clean. Perhaps Batman's next foe will
teach us more about what happened to the Arkhams.
The Riddler made his capture rather easy. Clearly,
he had an endgame in mind that the Gotham police
department wasn't privy to. And neither was
Batman, despite the Riddler's attempts to
enlighten him. When we see the Riddler sitting
on the opposite side of hardened glass talking
to Batman about his plan, viewers can see clearly
that he has an "Arkham State Hospital" suit on.
Why is the facility not referred to as
Arkham Asylum? Will the State Hospital
undergo changes after a new surge in
high-profile villains make their way into
police custody after being captured by Batman?
In the film "Joker," Joaquin Phoenix's version of
the character is seen standing outside of Arkham
State Hospital as well. Perhaps this is also the
version of Arkham we see in "The Batman."
Alfred Pennyworth is the closest
Bruce Wayne has to a family.
In most iterations of the character, he
is a faithful butler who served the family
for many years. He helped care for Bruce
following the tragic death of his parents.
In "The Batman," Alfred receives the wrath of
the Riddler by mistake as a mail bomb detonates.
The lethal package was actually meant for
Bruce. Fortunately, Alfred manages to survive,
although he's hospitalized in critical condition.
Later, Alfred reveals that he was the one who
taught Bruce to fight. As evidenced during
the fight sequences seen in "The Batman,"
those lessons must have included a whole
lot more than simply how to throw a punch.
If Batman's combat prowess is any
indication, Alfred is a formidable fighter.
Bruce's confidant also tries to help him
come to terms with feelings of guilt over
his parents' deaths. He reminds the crime
fighter that he was a young boy at the time.
Alfred explains that he was the one responsible
for protecting them. Does that mean Alfred
acts more like a bodyguard than a butler?
In the Earth One comic book storyline, Alfred is
a battle-hardened fighter who trained Bruce in all
that he knows. As a former member of the S.A.S.,
Alfred likely knew a thing or two about combat
and survival. Perhaps the Alfred we see in "The
Batman" shares a similar backstory.
Make no mistake, Batman can take a beating. That's
in no small part thanks to his apparently stellar
armor, although we don't really know exactly why
Batman's suit is so good at repelling damage.
There's obviously a heavy degree of Kevlar
involved. Batman takes several bullets
throughout the film, including a shotgun blast
directly to the chest, and he somehow manages
to walk away every time. That raises the
question, what is Batman's armor made of?
Kevlar can only do so much. It's pretty clear that
Bruce has some top-of-the-line gear. For example,
he wears a pair of contacts that work as spy
cameras capable of recording everything he sees.
At one point in the film, he has to escape the
police from inside the precinct. He and Jim
Gordon stage a faux assault and Batman flees to
the top of the building, where he leaps from the
roof to glide safely away from danger. He doesn't
exactly land gracefully, however. His parachute
catches a bridge and slams his body into a vehicle
and the concrete. It's a pretty nasty spill,
and he limps away in a significant amount of pain.
However, the whole engagement makes us wonder what
type of armor could possibly protect Batman from
colliding at a high speed with concrete and metal.
Fans know well that Batman
prepares for just about any probable scenario.
"Where does he get those wonderful toys?"
He often has access to a variety of tools
or gadgets that he might need to rely
on in a pinch in order to narrowly avert
catastrophe. In the final moments of the film,
Batman is fighting several of the Riddler's
followers, who are all armed to the teeth.
One particular baddie knocks the wind out
of the Dark Knight with a rather close-range
shotgun blast. Batman is visibly injured
and likely suffering from fractured ribs.
Selina Kyle enters the fray to save Batman
but quickly finds herself taking heat from
another goon. In an effort to save Selina,
Batman pulls out a strange green fluid
and injects himself with it, after which he
gets up and pummels his foe in a fit of rage.
Now, what do we know about a green fluid that
bolsters physical performance dramatically and
might even cause someone to lose control
of their anger? Bane might know the answer
to this question. Because, in the comics, Venom
is the name of a drug the back-breaking villain
uses in an attempt to overpower Batman. The
question "The Batman" viewers are left asking is:
Was that vial filled with Venom? If
so, why would Batman be carrying it?
At the start of "The Batman," the Penguin isn't
quite the high-profile gangster he's known for
being throughout his rich history in the comics.
When we first see him, he's still under Carmine
Falcone's thumb. Of course, this changes when the
Riddler murders Falcone, creating a power vacuum
in Gotham's organized crime structure that the
Penguin is poised to take full advantage of.
At the end of the film, we see a shot of the
Penguin contemplatively looking out at Gotham.
It's clear that he's about to ascend the ranks
of his criminal empire. So what does the future
hold for the Penguin after the credits roll?
Does this position him to be a prime target for
Batman in an upcoming sequel? At some point,
we'll be treated to a look at the Penguin prior
to the events of "The Batman" with his own spinoff
series on HBO Max. Perhaps the show will shed some
light on the character's plans for the future.
Batman's partnership with the GCPD,
and more specifically Jim Gordon, is one of the
most famous aspects of the Dark Knight's legacy.
In times of trouble, Police Commissioner
Jim Gordon often flips on the Batsignal
summoning the Caped Crusader. But in "The
Batman," Jim Gordon is still a lieutenant
and hasn't yet risen to the position of police
commissioner. That role belongs to Pete Savage.
Unfortunately for the commissioner, however, his
dirty deeds are brought to light by the Riddler.
Rather quickly, the villain releases a snuff film
of sorts putting Savage's demise on full display.
With murder and mayhem on the agenda for
Gotham, there isn't any time to discuss
replacements for the corrupt commissioner
during the events of "The Batman." However,
when the dust settles, perhaps Gordon will
be promoted to the job he's most famous for.
It's not a foregone conclusion, though. There are
those in the police force who don't condone Jim's
work with Batman. Still, it seems like a safe bet
that we'll see Gordon climb the ranks in a sequel,
opening more doors for the blossoming
partnership between the Dark Knight
and Gotham's police commissioner.
Coming from an affluent family, Bruce Wayne has
always enjoyed the luxuries of Wayne Manor. He
uses his family's private estate as a bunker-like
home base for his personal, professional,
and crime fighting operations. However, the
mansion is curiously absent from "The Batman."
Instead, Bruce seems to live in a skyscraper
looking down upon the city of Gotham.
His "Batcave" appears to be in an abandoned subway
tunnel. This raises the question of whether Wayne
Manor exists in Matt Reeves' version of the Batman
mythos. At one point, Riddler voices his disdain
for Bruce Wayne as a wealthy orphan who had
everything. He claims Bruce "looked down" upon
the less fortunate, suggesting that he might have
always lived in the skyscraper in Gotham City.
"Your family has a history of philanthropy, but
as far as I can tell, you're not doing anything."
However, if Wayne Manor and the Batcave do
exist, perhaps they're undergoing renovations
much like in "The Dark Knight" following Ra's
Al Ghul's assault on the Wayne home. There's
also potential for Bruce to build a new home
that's strategically placed over a cave he can
utilize for his operations.
The answer to this question varies depending
on which version of the Batman story you read,
watch, or hear. In some versions, Thomas and
Martha Wayne were simply in the wrong place
at the wrong time. The man named Joe Chill
is often referenced in Batman lore as the
thug who gunned down Bruce's parents. Other
versions of the story indicate that the mob
played a role in Thomas and Martha's deaths.
In "The Batman," Bruce confronts Carmine
Falcone over the deaths of his parents. He learns
a hard truth. Carmine claims Thomas Wayne came to
Falcone asking him for his help in dealing with
a reporter spreading harmful information about
Martha. Falcone, in a calculated move, had the
reporter killed. But as he goes on to tell Bruce,
he's also heard that his rival, Sal
Maroni, had Bruce's parents murdered.
Bruce then approaches Alfred with this
knowledge, and Alfred claims that Thomas
didn't realize Falcone would help him
by actually having the reporter killed.
"You lied to me, Alfred."
Burdened with guilt,
he resolved to go to the authorities but
was killed that night he planned to do it.
This leads Bruce to believe that it
was Falcone who killed his parents.
For his part, Alfred admits that he hoped to
find a smoking gun identifying the guilty party,
but was never able to do so. He can't confirm
whether Falcone did the deed. With Falcone dead
at the end of "The Batman," we won't hear more
from him about it. If another player was involved,
it'll likely play a pivotal role in Bruce's future
conflicts with the evil that plagues Gotham.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.